[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies herzlich willkommen an
diesem freitagabend fußball und mehr
gleich im sport von arbeitnehmern ist
von mir ja was die nachrichten angeht
sind die blicke zur zeit auf die
ukrainischen häfen gerichtet
hoffnung für die ukraine und die
weltpräsident selensky kündigt an dass
die ersten getreide schiffe nun starten
können
neue regeln für gasspeicher jetzt sind
höhere füllstände vorgeschrieben aber
können sie auch erreicht werden
und die jagd nach dem pokal beginnt
borussia dortmund will gegen 1860
münchen heute abend keine dieser
legendären überraschungen erleben
erstmals seit kriegsbeginn könnte die
ukraine heute oder morgen über die
schwarzmeer häfen getreide exportieren
die schiffe sind startklar nach mühsamen
verhandlungen hatten sich die ukraine
und russland vor einer woche auf das
abkommen zur getreide aus vor geeinigt
über die vorbereitung franziska von
tiesenhausen
es staubt mächtig während dieser
türkische frachter mit getreide beladen
wird seit kriegsbeginn im februar liegt
das schiff im hafen von chernomaz
südwestlich von odessa jetzt soll es
endlich wieder losfahren können das
kündigte der ukrainische präsident
zielinsky im beisein der g7 botschafter
an
was unsere seite ist vollständig
vorbereitet wir haben unseren partnern
den vereinten nationen und der türkei
alle signale gesendet und unser militär
garantiert für die sicherheitslage
noch wartet die ukraine auf die
bestätigung der sicheren schiffs
korridore durch die vereinten nationen
16 frachter werden aber nach
ukrainischen angaben bereits mit
getreide befüllt das entspricht einer
menge von mehr als 500.000 tonnen
insgesamt warten jedoch rund 20
millionen tonnen auf die ausfuhr
das export abkommen sieht vor dass sie
aus drei häfen im raum odessa über das
schwarze meer und den bosporus zu den
bestimmungshafen in aller welt gelangen
dort wird das korn sehnsüchtig erwartet
der un-generalsekretär hat es schon
gesagt dieses abkommen ist nicht nur
wichtig für die ukraine sondern es wird
auch dazu beitragen eine weltweite
nahrungsmittelkrise zu verhindern
für die ukraine ist der verkauf von
getreide eine wichtige einnahmequelle
und die lager müssen leer werden denn
die neue ernte wartet schon
wir haben es also gerade gesehene die
schiffe stehen bereit haben aber noch
nicht abgelegt eine brille ist vor ort
in odessa woran hängt es noch
ja gerade hat die ukraine mitgeteilt das
sind 17 schiffe die voll beladen in den
häfen von odessa und umgebung liegen
zehn davon sind sofort zur ausfahrt
bereit sagt man hier gewartet wird jetzt
noch auf 1 go der vereinten nationen und
der türkei die für sicherheits korridore
sorgen sollen hier in der ukraine gibt
es vor allen dingen eine sorge dass das
nämlich für die schiffe eine fahrt ohne
wiederkehr werden könnte denn in den
letzten tagen haben die russen immer
wieder raketen abgefeuert auf den hafen
von odessa aber auch auf die stadt die
ukraine ihrerseits hat die
hafeneinfahrten zu beginn des krieges
vermied aus sorge vor russischen
angriffen und so ist das hier eigentlich
die frage die alle beschäftigt wie
sicher können in diesen tagen und unter
diesen umständen solche transporte denn
eigentlich seien sie wenn das weiter für
uns beobachten auch so besser dankeschön
eine pool
und aus der region donetsk wird ein
verheerender luftangriff gemeldet für
den sich moskau und kiew gegenseitig
verantwortlich machen dabei sollen
mindestens 50 ukrainische
kriegsgefangene ums leben gekommen sein
offenbar auch mitglieder des asa
frequenz das gefangenenlager liegt im
besetzten gebiet daher gibt es nur
russisches bildmaterial moskau sieht in
dem beschluss eine warnung der ukraine
an die eigenen soldaten sich nicht zu
ergeben kiew sagt moskau habe mit dem
angriff auf das eigene camp folter und
hinrichtungen vertuschen wollen
schwere waffen war deutschland schon in
kleiner stückzahl an die ukraine
geliefert jetzt sollen auch sogenannte
brücken lege panzer folgen sechs bieber
so heißt das fahrzeug noch in diesem
weitere zehn im kommenden jahr das teilt
das verteidigungsministerium in berlin
mit
um auf den winter vorbereitet zu sein
müssen die gasspeicher möglichst schnell
gefüllt werden seit heute gelten da für
strengere vorschriften
schauen wir uns das in zahlen an
momentan sind deutschlands gasspeicher
erst 67 5 prozent gefüllt das
wirtschaftsministerium gibt jetzt ein
neues zwischenziel vor am ersten
september sollen es 75 prozent sein
erhöht worden sind die vorgaben für
oktober von bisher 80 auf 85 und zum
ersten november von 90 auf 95 prozent
aber wie realistisch sind diese ziele
oliver deuker und elisabeth schmidt es
wird ein kraftakt beispiele rehden
niedersachsen deutschlands größte
erdgasspeicher ist im moment nicht mal
zur hälfte gefüllt bis zum herbst soll
mehr als doppelt so viel gas rein
realistisch nennt dieses ziel die
bundesregierung die branche bleibt
skeptisch auch wenn wir jetzt ein
einspeichern von gas sehen und die
speicher füllstände steigen dürfen uns
nicht in falscher sicherheit wägen wir
müssen abwarten wie das wetter sich im
oktober entwickelt wie die heizperiode
starten wird
unsicherheitsfaktor bleibt russland dann
über die pipeline nord stream 1 fließen
zurzeit nur 20 prozent der vereinbarten
liefermenge zwar kauft deutschland
erdgas aus den niederlanden oder
norwegen zu doch die kapazitäten sind
ausgereizt die gasspeicher sollten auf
keinen fahrlehrer werden sagt der
wirtschaftsminister was wir verhindern
müssen ist da ist bei den hohen
gaspreisen die am spot markt zu erzielen
sind da es wieder aus gespeichert wird
aber was nicht gut wäre wäre wenn anfang
august die gasspeicher bei 90 sind und
auf einmal weil man geld macht sie ende
september nur noch bei
75 sind ganz wichtig seien neue
gasquellen zwei von vier schwimmenden
flüssigerdgas terminals sollen schon zum
jahreswechsel einsatzbereit sein eines
kommt nach wilhelmshaven trotzdem es
wird knapp in unseren szenarien werden
wir nicht auch ohne eine signifikante
einsparung und privaten bereich diesem
anlage vermeiden und dann geht natürlich
auch noch die hohen kosten im privaten
bereich zu vermeiden hohe kosten die
heizung runterdrehen alles hängt davon
ab wie viel gas deutschland bis zum
herbst ein speichern kann
um weniger abhängig von russischem gas
zu sein wird er mit hochdruck versucht
alternativen zu finden und auszubauen
eine davon heimisches biogas bisher
werden dadurch fast zehn millionen
haushalte mit strom versorgt und mehr
als eine million haushalte mit wärme so
der fachverband biogas aber es könnten
mehr sein welche rolle biogas spielen
kann das zeigt den oliver drecker
torsten kruse ist geschäftsführer der
biogasanlage rasche in niedersachsen die
energie mit silage aus mais rüben
pflanzenresten gülle und mist produziert
beim gären dieser zutaten entsteht gas
das vor ort in strom für 4000 haushalte
umgewandelt wird die abwärme der anlage
nutzen dazu 1500 haushalte außerdem geht
noch reines gas in das öffentliche netz
also unsere anlage hatten
durchschnittliche leistung von ungefähr
drei megawatt die stunde und wir könnten
das doppelte locker machen allein
niedersachsens biogasanlagenbetreiber
könnten zusammen bis zu 20% es bisher
aus russland importierten gases
kurzfristig ersetzen sagt der
landesverband erneuerbare energien wenn
man sie denn ließe wir haben im zuge der
genehmigung dieser biogasanlage eine
bestimmte biogas höchstmenge genehmigt
bekommen die dürfen wir im jahr nicht
überschreiten
wir würden das gerne tun weil wir die
rohstoffvorräte haben dürfen es aber
nicht weil es hart sanktioniert wird
biogasanlagen eine umweltfreundliche
kreislaufwirtschaft die ergänzend zu
wind und sonne immer energie produzieren
kann dieses potenzial wird aber bisher
verschenkt so die kritik an die politik
dann sicher dass wir sehr kurzfristig
auch entscheidung des bundes erleben
werden dass diese sozusagen maximal
produktion die manchmal festgelegt hat
aufgehoben wird weil jetzt in dieser
phase selbst dann bis nur befristet
machen brauchen wir die flexibilität des
einsatzes auch der biogasanlage aber wir
brauchen sie auch darüber hinaus dafür
aber mehr energiepflanzen und damit
weniger lebensmittel anzubauen lehnt
dies ab ein bundesweites hochfahren der
biogasanlagen berichte für bis zu vier
millionen weitere haushalte wärme und
strom
und wir schauen ins ausland von
griechenland aus ist die bundes
außenministerin heute in der türkei
eingetroffen
dabei wollte sie auch jene themen
ansprechen bei denen wir fundamentale
differenzen haben so bernburg wie die
menschenrechtslage zudem geht es um den
streit um gebiete zwischen den nato
partner türkei und griechenland berbalk
hat sich da jetzt auf die seite
griechenlands gestellt über den besuch
patricia wiedemeier es ist ein besuch
bei freunden und nato partnern dennoch
eine schwierige mission für annalena
baerbock erste station athen der empfang
beim außenminister betont freundlich
aber griechenland bleibt bei der
forderung nach reparationszahlungen für
die zeit der deutschen besatzung im
zweiten weltkrieg und dem angespannten
verhältnis zum nato partner türkei wird
mehr deutsche unterstützung erwartet
keine lieferung von u-booten
mit diesen worten ist die gefahr groß
dass das kräfteverhältnis im ost
mittelmeer aus den fugen gerät zu
gunsten eines landes das obwohl es eine
nato mitglied ist oft von kriegsfall
sprechen
ankara will erneut gas bohrschiffe in
griechisches hoheitsgebiet schicken wie
schon vor zwei jahren und hat
truppenstationierungen auf inseln in der
östlichen ägäis kritisiert die reaktion
von baerbock klar und deutlich
griechischen insel lesbos orders und
viele viele andere sind griechisches
territorium
und niemand hat das recht das in frage
zu stellen
deutschland stehe solidarisch an der
seite griechenlands so ihre botschaft
außenministerin baerbock weiß sie
braucht beide staaten griechenland und
die türkei für die flüchtlingsfragen
aber auch für die folgen des ukraine
krieg ist zwischen beiden staaten
vermitteln ohne dem einen oder anderen
auf die füße zu treten probleme lösung
durch dialog das ist hier die große
herausforderung für sie am späten
nachmittag dann zweiter teil der reise
ist dann wohl beim treffen mit dem
türkischen amtskollegen ging es vor
allem um den ukraine krieg wie eine
waffenruhe erreicht werden kann um
terrorismus noch dauern die gespräche an
ist ja gerade läuft noch die
pressekonferenz von annalena baerbock
und ihrem türkischen amtskollegen social
o und da zeigt sich die türkische seite
deutlich verstimmt deutschland habe
seine unparteiische vermittlerrolle
zwischen der türkei und griechenland
verloren zuvor hatte berg türkische
gebietsansprüche in der ägäis
zurückgewiesen
vor ziemlich genau einem jahr haben in
afghanistan ja wieder die
radikalislamischen taliban die macht
übernommen seitdem haben sich die sorgen
bestätigt gerade das leben von mädchen
und frauen wurde von den taliban spürbar
eingeschränkt so die
menschenrechtsorganisation amnesty
international
so dürfen sie zum beispiel keine weitere
führenden schulen und universitäten mehr
besucher unsere reporterin katrin
eigendorf war vor ort
gruß an kiel ein dorf am südlichen rand
von kabul abdul majeed hat uns in sein
haus eingeladen der familienvater hat
sieben töchter dass die taliban den
mädchen das recht auf bildung genommen
haben trifft ihn hart
wenn die taliban an der macht bleiben
können sie nur bis zur sechsten klasse
die schule besuchen wir können nichts
daran ändern
seitdem die selbst ernannten
gotteskrieger vor einem jahr die macht
übernommen haben hat sich auch die
wirtschaftliche lage der familie
dramatisch verschlechtert als tagelöhner
verdient der 48 jährige kaum genug um
die familie zu ernähren noch besuchen
die vier ältesten töchter die schule und
haben träume was möchtet ihr werden
frage ich sie
lehrerin
ärztin warum ärzte helfen den menschen
dass afghanistans mädchen und frauen das
recht auf bildung genommen wird stößt
international immer mehr auf kritik der
stellvertretende informationsminister
weist das zurück im gespräch besteht er
darauf nicht mit mir einer frau zusammen
im bild zu sehen zu sein
ich bestreite dass unser land sich nicht
um die bildung kümmert millionen mädchen
lernen gerade in den unterschiedlichsten
bildungseinrichtungen die frauen
afghanistans sind die großen
verliererinnen ein jahr nach der
machtübernahme der taliban haben sie
fast alle ihre mühsam errungenen rechte
und freiheiten verloren das könnte sich
für das land zunehmend zum problem
erweisen mit der zukunft ihrer töchter
steht für die familie man sieht auch die
eigene existenz auf dem spiel und sie
sind nicht die einzigen aus diesem grund
kritisieren auch viele afghanen
inzwischen die bildungspolitik der
taliban
hohe energiepreise teure lebensmittel
die inflationsrate im euroraum hatte im
juli mit 89 prozent einen neuen
höchstwert erreicht das teilte das
europäische statistikamt eurostat mit
deutschland liegt knapp unter dem wert
dagegen wurde es vor allem in den
baltischen staaten richtig teuer in
estland lettland und litauen stiegen die
inflationsraten auf knapp über 20
prozent
während im euroraum die wirtschaft
wächst stagniert die konjunktur in
deutschland das bruttoinlandsprodukt hat
sich im vergleich zum vorquartal nicht
verändert meldet das statistische
bundesamt trotz aller widrigkeiten zeigt
sich der arbeitsmarkt stabil im juli
waren zwei millionen 470.000 menschen
ohne job
107.000 mehr als im juni ein grund immer
mehr kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
werden erfasst die quote erhöhte sich um
0,2 punkte auf 5,4 prozent im vergleich
zum vergangenen juli sind heute 120.000
menschen weniger arbeitslos
der arbeitsmarkt bleibt also stabil
trotz corona trotz ukraine krieg und
doch ist eine deutliche veränderung zu
beobachten nämlich wie und wo oder
besser von wo aus die menschen arbeiten
immer mehr von zu hause nämlich das home
office setzt sich offenbar durch die
pandemie diese innovation beschleunigt
zeigt stefan schlosser
arbeitsbeginn am küchentisch carsten
brzeski ist chefvolkswirt der ing bank
und verantwortet ein team von mehr als
30 leuten seinen tagesablauf kann er
flexibel einteilen wie oft er ins büro
fährt selbst entscheiden seine
mitarbeiter können dass auch
ich muss nicht wissen wo und wie meine
mitarbeiter ihre arbeit erledigen wir
gezwungen dass sie ihre arbeit erledigen
dass die qualität groß ist wo man das
macht weil man das macht mir ziemlich
gehabt so sieht man das auch in der bank
durchschnittlich sind zurzeit nur 25 bis
30 prozent aller beschäftigten in den
büros der ing die anderen im home office
wir haben eine gleichbleibende
beziehungsweise steigende produktivität
festgestellt der zweite punkt ist die
sinkende krankheitsquote wir
festgestellt haben ein sehr positiver
effekt für das unternehmen und der
dritte punkt ist die steigerung der
mitarbeiterzufriedenheit
die wir durch umfragen festgestellt
haben bundesweit arbeitet rund jeder
vierte beschäftigte laut studien
teilweise in den eigenen vier wänden ein
trend der bleiben wird sagen experten
für unternehmen die ohne guten grund
kein home office anbieten wird es extrem
schwer talente fachkräfte zu rekrutieren
und beschäftigte zu halten haben wir es
wird extrem geschätzt von beschäftigten
und viele umfragen zeigen auch dass
beschäftigte bereit wären den job zu
wechseln wenn sie keine möglichkeit mehr
haben zu hause zu arbeiten wird
ausschließlich im home-office gearbeitet
können aber das persönliche der kontakt
mit den kollegen und auch die bindung an
das unternehmen verloren gehen deshalb
mag sich auch carsten brzeski nicht ganz
vom arbeitsplatz in der bank trennen
auch wenn es zu hause immer noch am
schönsten ist
weniger gas aus russland weniger
medikamente aus china und indien noch
eine lehre aus den krisenjahren es kann
sich rächen wenn man sich von einem oder
wenigen herstellern abhängig macht bei
102 mitteln gibt es derzeit engpässe und
so fehlt gerade jetzt in der urlaubszeit
ein eigentlich unverzichtbares produkt
unter familien reiseapotheke fieber saft
für kinder anna gehört
am kinderfreundlichen geschmack tüfteln
sie noch bald aber soll die selbst
hergestellte arznei fertig sein denn
paracetamol und ibuprofen haltige fieber
säfte sind hier wie anderswo vergriffen
nachschub nicht lieferbar so eine
extreme situation dass wir wirklich egal
wo wir anfragen beim hersteller beim
großhandel bei verschiedenen firmen das
wirklich nicht lieferbar die hatten wir
noch nie hauptgrund für den engpass ein
hersteller stellte die produktion vor
einigen monaten ein die nachfrage bei
anderen anbietern stieg so stark dass
manche apotheken jetzt leer ausgehen
lieferengpässe gehören in den apotheken
seit jahren zum alltag im grunde
genommen wird es immer schlimmer wir
sind abhängig in der produktion von
china um in die chinesen nicht liefern
dann haben wir eben auch einen engpass
42 lieferengpass erstmeldung im jahr
2013 im vergangenen jahr waren es 381
immer weniger immer größere
produktionsstätten vor allem in china
und indien stellen unter anderem die
wirkstoffe her es zählt der niedrigste
preis nur der billigste gewinnt und
billig wird man eben am ehesten wenn man
alle kosten rausnimmt wenn man total
verschlankt und es gibt sicher auch die
liefersicherheit mehr fokus auf
verlässliche lieferketten fordert auch
die anschütten helm und zumindest teile
der produktion zurück nach europa zu
holen beim biber saft könnte sich die
situation im herbst wieder entspannen
bis dahin lohnt es sich in der apotheke
nach alternativen zu fragen die können
auch mal selbst gemacht sein
und lieferengpässe gibt es nicht nur bei
fieber saft sondern es fehlen auch
lebenswichtige medikamente für chronisch
kranke weitere informationen dazu finden
sie online jederzeit in unserer zeit
erfreute
und heutige schon wieder einen großen
fußballabend im zdf nicht die em in
england sondern dfb pokal ja und dann
gibt es gleich zum auftakt eines dieser
david gegen goliath spiele die den pokal
ja so spannend machen 1860 münchen gegen
den bvb drittligist gegen vize meister
katrin müller hohenstein in münchen hat
das fußball fest denn schon angefangen
oh
ja das wird für den bvb heute ein echter
hexenkessel 15.000 gehen rein ins
stadion an der grünwalder straße und sie
sind unterwegs es hat einen fanmarsch
gegeben treffpunkt 16 30 dann ging es
durch diesen kam mit strasserauf direkt
zum stadion das letzte
aufeinandertreffen der beiden gab es
2003 den pokal damals haben die löwen
den bvb in die verlängerung gezwungen am
ende hat dortmund zwei zu null gewonnen
aber die hoffnung die lebt natürlich
auch heute wieder die level sind schon
da und wir melden uns dann ab 20 15 live
aus münchen danke katrin und sonntag um
diese uhrzeit ja der rollt der ball
schon im wembley stadion das traumfinale
england gegen deutschland vor 90.000
zuschauern das duell der beiden besten
teams des turniers und der beiden besten
teams mit gegen alexandra popp
die deutsche em helden zielsicher nicht
nur auf dem platz auch mit ihrem humor
trifft pop ins schwarze
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in anspielung darauf dass viele bereits
ihrem einsatz bei der männer-wm fordern
hat sie die lacher auf ihrer seite
sechs mal schon hat die dfb kapitän in
bei dieser em getroffen genauso oft wie
die beste englische torschütze inbev mit
aber in einem ist sie ihre rivalin
voraus vorlagen verwertet ob auch neben
dem platz
zur tour de france der frauen da hat die
niederländerin marianne vos ihren
zweiten etappensieg eingefahren die
35-jährige setzten sich nach 129
kilometern im sprint der spitzengruppe
ungefährdet durch und verteidigte damit
ihr gelbes trikot als gesamtführender
beste deutsche im zieljahr lippert auf
platz 24
johann morgen dann die königsetappe der
tour mit drei schweren bergwertung
dankeschön rand der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt aktuell vor schwerem
gewitter mit heftigem starkregen und
schweren böen im norden bayerns alles
weitere zum wetter gleich von katja
hornuf das heute-journal können sie
gegen halb zehn seen mit mitri sirin und
zwar in der halbzeitpause des dfb pokals
[Musik]
guten abend sommerferien in deutschland
und temperaturen wie am mittelmeer gibt
es ja in diesem sommer oft auch bei uns
das mittelmeer selbst hat zur zeit sehr
hohe wassertemperaturen zwischen 26 und
29 grad wie viel angenehmer sind da
unsere nacht werte bei 17 bis 11 grad es
gibt allerdings sehr kräftige gewitter
die können punktuell überschwemmungen
bringen und starkregen besonders in
sachsen thüringen und auch in bayern
morgen ziehen diese kräftigen schauer
und gewitter ganz langsam ostwärts ab am
freundlichsten wird zwischen berlin und
der ostseeküste und zwischen norderney
und dem oberhalb die temperaturen unter
diesen dichteren wolken mit schauern und
gewittern liegen meist nur soweit 20 bis
22 grad genauso wie auch an der küste am
wärmsten wird es am oberrhein mit 30
grad der sonntag bringt uns dann viel
sonnenschein nur im nordwesten gibt es
die ersten schauer die temperaturen
steigen schon etwas an und nach einem
etwas wechselhaften montag deutet sich
dann die nächste kurze hitzewelle an
jedenfalls ein zwei tage könnten die
temperaturen wieder bis an die 38 grad
steigen schönen abend noch